quand vous avez appris et vous avez
entendu il est condamné à 10 ans de
prison je crois que ça a été pour tout
le monde une claque absolument
monumentale
ça peut être possible
c'est énorme 10 ans de foutu en l'air 10
ans de sa vie
je trouvais que un innocent condamné à
tort et ce qui a pu terrible quoi
ils sont deux
deux hommes que tout oppose et pourtant
ils ont un point commun un jour ils ont
été accusés à tort
des histoires différentes pour une même
souffrance pour eux tout a commencé par
un mensonge un mensonge qui leur a coûté
plusieurs mois derrière les barreaux
simple citoyen Hassan chafa est devenu
le coupable idéal dans une histoire de
braquage
pierre royale directeur d'école a été
condamné pour un viol qu'il n'a pas
commis
leur parcours m'interpelle et me fait me
poser une question comment se
reconstruire après une bataille contre
la machine judiciaire
[Musique]
je m'appelle Pierre Royal j'ai 52 ans
j'ai passé 10 mois dans ce trou à rat la
maison d'arrêt de Riom suite à un procès
bâclé et une erreur judiciaire
je m'appelle Hassan chafaille j'ai 35
ans et j'ai été accusé à tort de
braquage
pierre ce sont retrouvés sans raison sur
le banc des accusés une vie qui bascule
un jour injustement afin de prouver leur
innocence tous deux se sont battus face
au système judiciaire
[Musique]
Hassan chafaille carrossier de formation
via Grenoble dans cet immeuble d'un
quartier populaire
son histoire commence en août 2002
Hassan décide de partir en vacances en
Espagne des vacances durant lesquelles
il va rencontrer une jeune australienne
ça c'est les vacances
on va dire on profite de la vie de jeune
25 ans on va dire un peu l'insouciance
encore chez Maman donc
ce qu'ignorent Hassan c'est qu'au même
moment il est surveillé par la police
nationale une fois les vacances finies
il décide de rejoindre sa petite amie à
Nice pour un week-end c'est le matin de
8h30 9h donc devant l'hôtel c'est le
gérant de l'hôtel qui nous avait pris en
photo j'aurais jamais pu penser à qui
puisse m'arriver un truc comme ça qu'on
va dire dans les films et voilà quoi
c'est ça la télé quoi c'est pas dans la
réalité
il est 10h30 ce 14 août 2002 quand
Hassan quitte Nice il arrive à Grenoble
en milieu d'après-midi
ignorant qu'un braquage de banque a eu
lieu pendant son voyage de retour
je vais sur un banc donc en fait j'étais
facilement reconnaissable j'avais un
t-shirt bleu avec la signe de Superman
service de police qui passe derrière
donc il me reconnaisse il me dit chava
Yassine m'interpelle oui oui c'est bien
moi je dois sur ma carte d'identité ils
me dis ce contrôle à l'hôtel de police
donc pas de problème je monte dans le
véhicule on m'amène à l'hôtel de police
donc je monte dans l'ascenseur
et un moment ils ouvrent une porte et il
y a un policier qui dit oui oui c'est
bien c'est lui
bon je me suis posé des questions en ce
moment-là bon après voilà ils m'ont
c'est à partir de là tout a commencé
donc
[Musique]
ça ne va passer deux jours dans cet
hôtel de police
48 heures entre les interrogatoires et
sa cellule où il éclame son innocence
à ce moment là il me dit exactement en
garde à vue pour pour voilà marmer bande
organisé ou je sais plus le terme exact
donc
on me note et à partir de là comment
c'est interrogatoire sur 48 heures donc
48 heures j'ai dû je sais pas peut-être
10 interrogatoires bah ils essayent de
me faire avouer quoi j'essaie de me
faire avouer ils reviennent
depuis quand essayer et voilà quoi j'ai
toujours gardé la même version puisque
voilà c'était la vérité tout le long de
la garde à vue on me dit qu'il y a un
policier qui m'a reconnu puis il m'a vu
devant la banque d'ailleurs il me dit
que je suis passé et à retirer la
cagoule devant lui
ce policier est justement sur la piste
d'une bande de braqueurs depuis
plusieurs mois il aurait reconnu en
Hassan l'un des délinquants recherchés
Hassan ne le sait pas encore mais un
élément joue en sa défaveur peu de temps
auparavant il a acheté une voiture à
l'un des braqueurs soupçonnés
tout de suite on oublie à cette personne
c'est que par là tout commence quoi je
l'achète à une personne qui est qui est
soupçonnée déjà braquage antérieur déjà
en braquage qui est voilà qui est mis
sous surveillance donc automatiquement
dès que j'achète le véhicule les
policiers va me mettre sous surveillance
il me surveille
un simple achat de voiture qui le relie
à une bande de braqueurs qui sévit dans
la région depuis des mois
pour les policiers
l'interpellation d'un braqueur soupçonné
est un soulagement
arrêter les braqueurs qui n'arrivent pas
arrêter depuis des mois donc des petits
jeunes qui faisaient des braquages dans
Grenoble dans ce climat tendu après 48
heures de garde à vue Hassan chafa y est
un coupable idéal il est conduit devant
le juge d'instruction du palais de
justice de Grenoble qui va le mettre en
examen
ce juge là dit que je suis coupable donc
voilà vous êtes accusé de voir la main
mais je vous mets en détention voilà
là je réalise vraiment je me dis ça y
est je vais aller en prison quoi parce
que moi tout le long je prends c'est
franchement je faisais confiance quoi je
me rappelle je me voilà quoi je l'arme
aux yeux je pleure et je voyais le
procureur qui avait grand sourire je lui
dis vous verrez vous regretterez vous
mettez un innocent en prison et il garde
son grand sourire
Jean-Marc Florent vous êtes avocat oui
on vient de le voir à sanchafa est mis
en garde à vue sur le seul témoignage
d'un policier
quels sont les éléments qui permettent
aux forces de l'ordre de mettre un
suspect en garde à vue il faut en
principe en théorie qui vient un certain
nombre d'éléments
importants graves précis ou cordon qui
permet de sérieusement de penser et
qu'une infraction peut avoir été commise
par la personne que l'on va placer en
garde à vue alors Hassan a été mise en
cause par un policier est-ce que c'est
difficile encore aujourd'hui de remettre
en cause cette parole du policier alors
ça reste difficile parce que la place du
policier dans le système judiciaire
n'est pas la place de monsieur tout le
monde sa parole à une valeur supérieure
à celle du témoin lambda ou de
l'accusateur lambda parce qu'il est
policier les magistrats notamment ont
souvent du mal à envisager que le
policier ait pu mentir dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions
évoque le grand sourire du procureur
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'en France
malgré les lois on reste malgré tout
présumé coupable lorsque vous avez un
casier judiciaire qui est déjà important
vous avez quand même de fortes chances
que le procureur et un grand sourire au
nom de l'idée que vu le casier bon bah
vous avez certainement récidiver et on
se pose et vous partirez quand même
revêtu d'une présomption de culpabilité
alors ce qui est ce qui est
naturellement très inquiétant parce que
la règle c'est la présomption
d'innocence c'est pas parce que vous
avez 5 6 10 condamnations casier que
pour cette affaire ou des faits ou son
prochain vous les avez commis
judiciaire alors il est vrai aussi que
je dirais le passé des gens l'histoire
familiale les origines géographiques les
origines familiales sont comment dire
souvent culturellement
permettent un glissement vers une
présomption de culpabilité
[Musique]
plein de pensent que le simple fait
d'être innocent le fera sortir
rapidement de prison mais le destin va
en décider autrement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui quand Pierre royale 52 ans
se rend devant son ancien lycée il reste
à l'extérieur
cette institut catholique de
Clermont-Ferrand il l'a pourtant dirigé
pendant près de 15 ans c'était ma vie
mon travail moi j'arrivais ici à 7h le
matin je repartais vers 11h minuit
combien un internat il faut aller aussi
s'en occuper faire une présence au
niveau des élèves donc oui effectivement
pour moi c'est mon métier était ma vie
c'est clair
à l'époque Pierre royale est un
directeur apprécié par les élèves et
leurs parents ils mènent une vie sans
histoire c'est quelque chose dont on est
absolument pas préparé surtout lorsqu'on
a déjà plus de vingtaine d'années de
direction derrière soi on pense que ça
arrive toujours aux autres quand on
pense pas que ça puisse nous tomber
dessus donc c'est vrai que ça vraiment
été une grande surprise
en février 2000 pierre royale directeur
d'école est convoqué par la brigade des
mineurs sera ils seront au commissariat
je ne m'inquiète pas outre mesure dans
ma carrière il est fonctions que j'ai
occupées j'ai plusieurs fois été
convoqué par la police concernant des
anciens élèves ou pour les conflits
familiaux donc j'ai envie de dire
c'était pour moi un peu la routine du
métier j'arrive aux commissariat et la
première phrase que j'entends c'est
Monsieur à partir de maintenant comment
sauvegarde à vue j'ai commencé ma
garde-à-vis oui vous êtes visé par une
plainte l'une de vos anciennes élèves
pour viol par personne n'ayant autorité
l'effet aurait eu lieu deux ans
auparavant
une de ses anciennes élèves âgées de 15
ans l'accuse de l'avoir violée dans son
bureau voici le récit qu'elle donne aux
policiers
mon adjointe qui était une religieuse
était allée la chercher à l'internat
pour lui dire que je voulais la voir et
cette élève dit donc elle a été violée
qu'elle est rentrée ensuite à l'internat
en pleurs et que le week-end où elle est
rentrée à la maison elle a pris sa
culotte elle a tout brûlé
et je fais ça dans la rivière qui passe
à côté de chez elle pierre royale est
gardé 36 heures au commissariat mais il
est finalement relâché quelques mois
plus tard faute de preuves l'affaire est
classée sans suite pierre royale reprend
le cours de sa vie j'ai repris tout de
suite mon travail à mon bureau et
j'ai repris immédiatement le cours
normal de mes activités professionnelles
et personnelles
mais trois ans plus tard contre toute
attente le dossier va connaître son
premier rebondissement la jeune fille
devenue majeure va de nouveau déposer
plainte
mais cette fois-ci le juge d'instruction
va prendre très au sérieux ses
accusations de viol un procès aura lieu
en juin 2004 devant la Cour d'Assise du
Puy-de-Dôme
je crois beaucoup aux institutions de
mon pays donc j'arrive à mon procès très
serein très confiant sachant que le
dossier étant totalement vide je ne peux
être quitté donc je j'arrive où il y
avait beaucoup de sérénité
[Musique]
la parole de l'enfant est-elle toujours
quelque chose de sacré depuis le
désastre d'Outreau je dirais
l'institution judiciaire est beaucoup
plus prudente avec d'abord la mettre
dans tes recueillie la parole de
l'enfant et le contenu de la parole de
l'enfant on l'a compris qu'un enfant
prémentir on a compris également que la
parole de l'enfant pouvait être tout à
fait polluer par des événements
extérieurs par des tiers ou mal
recueillis c'est-à-dire interpréter de
travers par des policiers ou des
gendarmes ou des psychologues qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment de recul de
culture et de formation pour apprécier
objectivement le contenu la parole de
l'enfant est-ce que les juges et les
forces de l'ordre sont davantage formés
pour ça alors il est clair que dans les
grandes villes de mon Paris lorsqu'il y
a les brigades des mineurs très
spécialisés il y a des enquêteurs hommes
ou femmes qui ont reçu une formation
particulièrement appropriée au recueil
la parole de l'enfant lorsque c'est des
affaires qui tombent dans des petites
villes et je dirais dans des brigades où
il y a pas de personnel formés on en est
resté dans la situation d'avant la
parole est recueillie elle est filmée ce
qui est un progrès mais la manière
cueilli ou présentée ou interprété
ou retaper sur PV restera quand même
assez artisanal comment expliquer que
les crimes sexuels fassent partie des
fausses accusations les plus fréquentes
contrairement à des affaires
d'assassinat demeure de braquage ce sont
la plupart du temps des affaires où il y
a pas de témoin c'est à dire que
personne selon la formule populaire de
tient la chandelle et ses paroles de
l'un l'adulte je l'ai pas fait ou la
personne était consentante parole de
l'autre j'étais pas consentante où il
l'a fait bon et plus les faits sont
éloignés du moment du jugement on
demande des explications à l'adulte plus
c'est compliqué d'avoir des aimants
objectifs plus d'ADN pas de précision
géologique pas d'expertise alors après
ce sont généralement des témoignages
indirects ce sont des je dirais des
récits plus ou moins inventés ou
inventés ou retranscrit donc ça laisse
une marge à l'erreur qui est beaucoup
plus importante que pour des affaires de
sang
[Musique]
pierre Royal est persuadé que la justice
va reconnaître son innocence mais il est
loin d'imaginer l'issue de son procès
[Musique]
à Grenoble le 16 août 2002 après deux
jours de garde à vue Hassan qui clament
toujours son innocence et présenter
devant le juge d'instruction
reconnu formellement par le policier qui
a assisté au braquage il est placé en
détention provisoire pour tentative de
vol à Marmé alors qu'il n'était pas à
Grenoble au moment des faits
judiciaire donc
ouais j'ai jamais eu à faire à la
justice de cette manière là on va dire
ça a été quand même violent j'arrive
même pas même pas 3h après boom ça y est
garde à vue 48 heures
interrogatoire et voilà quoi après après
48 heures mandat de dépôt et on se
demande si c'est pas voilà un cauchemar
un mauvais rêve et je vais me réveiller
quoi et pourtant l'emprisonnement va
durer plusieurs mois derrière les
barreaux privés de liberté Hassan chafa
y vit mal sa détention
le problème un innocent qui est en
prison il a rien à se dire
bah voilà c'est dû à ça non c'est
qu'est-ce que je fais là chaque minute
chaque seconde qui passe et pourquoi je
suis là voilà quoi il y a jamais en fait
il y a jamais de pause il y a jamais de
pause je sais que bon voilà c'est ma
mère le plus qui a été le plus affecté
je sais que elle voilà quoi voir son
enfant rentrer en prison en sachant déjà
même un coupable on voit son enfant en
prison ça fait mal donc là qui est un
Telli il est innocent et qui en plus
tout est fait pour lui faire porter le
chapeau c'est
je pense c'est pas mesurable c'est
un truc voilà c'est voilà moi pour moi
ma mère a plus un plus du mal
intérieurement que moi ça je suis
persuadé parce que je connais un peu je
connais ma mère donc je sais comment
aller à quel point elle tient à nous et
ça ouais ça m'a c'est vrai que ça ça me
faisait c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours
voulu garder le sourire devant elle et
[Musique]
peut-être que peut-être qu'il y aurait
pas eu je sais pas il y aurait pas eu ma
famille aurait pas eu ma mère j'aurais
peut-être lâcher prise et j'aurais voilà
quoi je sais pas je sais pas ce qui
serait passé en fait j'ai toujours
essayé de garder d'être positif de
garder le sourire
tenir bon grâce à sa mère mais aussi
grâce à Ahmed son ami d'enfance il se
connaisse depuis la maternelle ils ont
grandi ensemble dans le quartier des
desserts à Grenoble
Ahmed comme de nombreux proches va très
mal vivre cette injustice
ce n'est pas exagéré de vous dire que
c'est du Rhin c'est de voir quelqu'un
qui
était incarcéré mais de se sentir
impuissant mais totalement totalement
impuissant de se dire que on sait qu'ils
n'ont pas de preuve
pour pour ce qui lui reproche on sait
qu'ils ont pas de preuve parce que ce
n'est pas lui
et les choses elles changent pas je vous
dis au bout d'un moment on finit même
par dire ils vont peut-être jamais
lâcher
ils vont peut-être jamais lâcher c'est
injustice nous on vient directement la
vie très mal mais j'ose imaginez
à scène qu'il a vraiment directement il
est enfermé entre 4 murs en lui dis
qu'un se laver on lui dit 15 sorties on
lui dit qu'un manger
je veux bien je veux bien moi ces règles
mais quand on est responsable de quelque
chose quand on a fait quelque chose
voilà c'est payer sa dette et
petit à petit Ahmed va voir son ami
changé se renfermer face à cette épreuve
il y a un assène avant la faire et à la
scène après l'affaire
donc il y a perdu qui a perdu une part
de de jovialité qui avait en lui
psychologiquement et des fois et des
impacts qui sont plus profonds qu'on ne
le pense c'est ce qui a été choquant en
fait de
qu'on ait permis d'incarrer quelqu'un
sans aucune preuve pour des faits aussi
graves la présomption d'innocence là
elle a été inexistante
au bout de quatre mois de détention
Hassan va changer de prison et le sort
va s'acharner contre lui lors de la
promenade il va tomber nez à nez avec
celui qu'il pensait être le véritable
coupable incarcéré pour une autre
affaire et là je me retrouve avec le
braqueur
avec qui on m'aurait confondu donc là
c'est le bon son Grenoble tout le monde
tout le monde savait stick donc là
dessus il y avait pas de doute un moment
je vais je vais lui parler je lui
demande si voilà quoi s'il peut avouer
pour me sortir de la mer je lui dis moi
j'ai rien à voir tu sais très bien je
dis c'est toi qui l'a fait tout le monde
le sait dans Grenoble donc il habite
c'est un quartier on se connaît un peu
tous les jeunes tout ça quoi moi il dit
non bon on se recroise plus et je me
rappelle que j'avais cette image j'étais
voilà j'étais en cellule et je le voyais
lui en promenade qui souriait parce
qu'on a été pas dans le même étage donc
il sourit tout ça bon voilà entre la
différence entre quelqu'un et qui a fait
il peut garder le sourire et moi je
l'avais pas le sourire
vous êtes psychiatre vous avez été
interne à la prison de Fresnes est-ce
qu'on peut se sentir coupable ou
éprouver de la culpabilité alors même
qu'on est innocent bien sûr tout à fait
tout à fait je pense même que c'est un
très gros obstacle l'élaboration de la
vérité il fait déjà vu c'est un
processus qui peut arriver on peut
reconnaître des choses alors qu'on est
innocent
parce que je pense que la culpabilité
d'une quelque chose de très de très
profond et
dont on a bien du mal à rendre compte
chez nos patients mais c'est fréquent
pour obtenir des aveux de jouer sur la
culpabilité des gens je pense que
effectivement des interrogates par
biennés peuvent mener à des aveux donc
qui tiennent pas debout on a du mal à
imaginer ce que représente la mise en
détention qui est plus est pour une
personne innocente on se demande ce qui
permet de tenir à ce moment-là je pense
que c'est le sentiment de révolte et
puis les perspectives qu'on peut
entrevoir de sortir de là ou de se
sortir de là paradoxalement le sentiment
d'injustice peut-il être une force et
puis je pense il faut l'accepter parce
que c'est ça qui permet aux gens
justement d'aller faire le point d'aller
prouver le contraire d'aller de se faire
aider de
cette un élément de la vie
[Musique]
le moral d'Assan est au plus bas il ne
voit pas d'issue à sa détention mais son
histoire va connaître un rebondissement
inespéré
[Musique]
c'est toujours aussi vert et c'est
toujours aussi beau chez vous en avril
2004 pierre royale s'apprête à être jugé
pour viol
aujourd'hui il rend visite à ses amis en
rillettes et Pierre Laffont le fontjoie
ils ont été témoins de ce procès et sont
parmi ses plus fervents
des parents d'élèves présentent dès le
début de la ferme
du procès on a encore mangé ensemble au
restaurant
manger des fruits de mer et ça c'est un
bon
et elle avait dit mais arrête de
racontes pas des bêtises tu sais très
bien ce qu'il en est mais non dans trois
jours et puis tu me disais on se
retrouvera pour refaire encore un
plateau de fruits de mer etc la claque a
été d'autant plus grande à l'énoncer du
verdict à Riom un verdict qui tombe
après trois jours d'un procès mené au
patchage les plaidoiries durent jusqu'à
5 heures du matin
une justice qui a choqué le président de
son comité de soutien
[Musique]
j'ai vu les les jurés dormir les
assesseurs dormir
pendant le pendant les plaidoiries de
ton avocat c'est le seul métier où on
accepte des des on prend des décisions
aussi importantes pour la vie de Jean à
trois quatre heures du matin comment ça
se fait ça c'est pas possible il y a pas
d'autres métiers où on fait ça est-ce
que c'est normal est-ce que est-ce que
les jurys ont tout entendu tout écouter
tout compris c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible
après trois jours d'audience le jury se
retire pour délibérer et le verdict va
être un véritable choc
et à 5h30 du matin je reviens donc cette
fois-ci dans le box et je m'entends dire
par le président Pierre Royal est-il
coupable du viol la réponse est oui et
je suis condamné à 10 ans de prison et
là c'est un monde complet qui s'écroule
autour de moi je me lève jeudi au
président mais c'est une erreur
judiciaire que vous êtes en train de
commettre ce n'est qu'une erreur de plus
je suis innocent vous n'avez aucune
preuve dans ce dossier comment
osez-vous me condamner
et là on me retire dans une petite pièce
on me passe les menottes et à travers le
souterrain on m'amène à la maison
d'arrêt
pierre royale s'apprête à passer sa
première nuit en prison
[Musique]
incarcéré depuis quatre mois en
détention provisoire Hassan tente par
tous les moyens de prouver son innocence
il multiplie les courriers au juge qui
instruit son affaire
comment les lettres que j'envoie
juste un truc sans pour essayer de
prouver mon innocence madame le juge je
vous écris ce courrier pour vous
demander si vous pourriez faire les
démarches suivantes avoir aussi une
confrontation avec tous les témoins et
employés de la banque
[Musique]
des lettres qui vont rester sans réponse
jusqu'à la nomination d'une nouvelle
juge d'instruction fin 2002 elle va
jouer un rôle déterminant dans le
dossier
Hassan a gardé de bons contacts avec
elle il la retrouve aujourd'hui pour
parler de la ferme lorsque j'arrive donc
en septembre 2002 au à l'instruction au
tribunal de Grenoble il y a eu toute une
série de braquages assez violents qui se
sont passés au cours de l'été au cours
du printemps et donc il y a un climat
les auteurs n'ont pas forcément été
interpellés les auteurs de ses braquages
et il y a un climat de tension qui règne
aussi bien au sein des services de
police que
au sein du tribunal parce que
effectivement les uns et les autres
cherchent à arrêter cette série de
braquage qui qui sont souvent encore une
fois violents qui se passent en plein
jour en plein centre-ville c'est un
petit peu ça le climat en septembre 2002
un mois plus tard elle prend
connaissance du dossier de Hassan
chafaille et plusieurs points vont
retenir son attention
dès le début il y a des éléments qui
m'interpellent des éléments sur
l'implication
supposée d'Assan Chafi sanchafa n'est
pas connu ni des services de police ni
de la justice puisqu'il n'a jamais été
condamné et que les faits qu'on lui
reproche à ce moment-là sont quand même
des faits très graves des faits de casse
à la voiture bélier qui suppose un
certain entraînement qui suppose une
certaine habitude de la criminalité ce
qui n'est absolument pas démontré pour
Hassan dans ce dossier là à aucun moment
on ne démontre que Hassan chafae connaît
les deux autres qui sont mises en cause
à aucun moment on ne démontre qu'il y a
eu des contacts la veille ou les jours
précédents entre ces deux personnes qui
elles sont impliquées de façon formelle
dans ce dossier lorsqu'on prépare un
effet pareil on se concerte auparavant
on se concerne soit on se voit soit on
se téléphone et là on ne démontre pas
que ça faille était en contact avec les
deux autres personnes ni même qu'il les
connaissait
elle le convoque alors dans son bureau
l'interrogatoire va durer une journée
entière
je l'interroge notamment sur tous ces
éléments là je l'interroge à ce
moment-là je dirais dans la plénitude de
mon métier à charge et à décharge c'est
à dire que lorsqu'il me dit quelque
chose je ne me dis pas il nous raconte
des bêtises je me dis pourquoi pas et ce
pourquoi pas là je le transforme en
suite en question et cette
interrogatoire là a été il a duré 8
heures je crois on a tout balayé
absolument tout balayer je suis revenue
plusieurs fois sur de nombreux éléments
pour me faire un petit peu une
conviction et lorsqu'il quitte mon
cabinet ce jour-là il ferme la porte et
je me souviens très bien que je me suis
tournée vers ma greffière en lui disant
à sanchafa est innocent
une intime conviction qu'il faut
maintenant prouver
en parallèle l'avocat d'Assan chafaille
fait pour la 4e fois une demande de
remise en liberté elle est accordée le
16 janvier 2003 après 5 mois de
détention il est libéré sous certaines
conditions
le short de prison sous contrôle
judiciaire donc je vais coincer tous les
jours à l'Hôtel de Police voilà quoi à
l'hôtel de police de Grenoble donc où il
y a les policiers qui font l'enquête moi
c'était très contraignant en fait
d'aller tous les jours c'est dur bon
c'est sûr que c'est mieux que c'est
mieux que d'être en détention mais le
truc c'est qu'on y pense tous les jours
on y pense tous les jours il y a pas un
truc qu'on souffle quand on est on se
dit bon c'est derrière
un an après sa libération en novembre
2004 le juge d'instruction va avoir
assez de preuves pour déclarer un
non-lieu pour Hassan elle met alors en
examen le véritable braqueur pendant un
an celui-ci va nier l'effet laissant
planer le doute sur la culpabilité
d'Assan jusqu'au procès du braqueur en
novembre 2005 le jour du tribunal
revirement de situation il
a voulu faire donc il dit oui c'est moi
plus grande joie ça a été ouais ça a été
à ce moment-là du au moment il avoué là
il y avait voilà quoi il y avait plus de
doute possible
Hassan est enfin lavé de tout soupçon
une satisfaction pour lui mais aussi
pour Marie-Laure mas après ça tous les
ans il m'a envoyé
une carte et la portée d'ailleurs une
carte de bonne année et
pour moi c'est quelque chose qui qui m'a
porté et qui continuent à me porter dans
l'exercice de mon métier parce qu'il est
pas toujours facile ce métier on fait ce
métier là pour les gens qu'on a devant
nous les justiciables ceux qui ont
affaire à la justice
et c'est bien d'avoir de temps en temps
des soutiens comme ça de savoir que
voilà
c'est une belle satisfaction c'est vrai
c'est une belle satisfaction pour moi
Bertrand Girin vous êtes spécialiste de
la réputation numérique autrement dit de
notre réputation sur Internet pour
parler clairement on peut être innocenté
par la justice mais restez condamné sur
Internet tout à fait en fait internet il
y a eu aujourd'hui un une mémoire sans
fin les moteurs de recherche ont horreur
du Gide donc ils trouvent des
informations sur vous et surtout il
n'oublie rien donc vous pouvez avoir ou
traîner un boulet numérique au pied même
si vous êtes innocenté dans la vie
réelle et ça veut dire que ces
informations ne seront jamais effacées
j'ai été accusé à tort j'ai fait la une
des journaux ça restera toujours sur
internet alors on a fait éventuellement
la une des journaux à un moment les
journaux ils disparaissent mais internet
ça reste et les moteurs de recherche ça
reste donc on peut avoir ce problème en
fait d'information négatives qui perdure
en fait et c'est là où ça pose problème
il peut y avoir des recours juridiques
et là et là c'est le rôle des avocats et
heureusement donc il y a un encadrement
par la loi dans les cas de diffamation
de nendigment donc aujourd'hui la loi
permet de faire des choses ça veut dire
quand même que techniquement on peut
quand même effacer avec l'avocat avec
les procédures etc tout à fait vous
pouvez pas demander un moteur de
recherche d'effacer si vous n'avez pas
une requête en fait parce qu'un moteur
de recherche ça défense c'est bien c'est
tout automatique donc je ne vais pas
vous faire quelque chose de spécial pour
vous sauf si la justice me demande
[Musique]
après l'épreuve traumatisante de la
prison comment Hassan va-t-il se
reconstruire
[Musique]
lors d'un procès qui a duré trois jours
pierre royale accusé de viol et condamné
à 10 ans de prison à une voix près au
mois d'avril 2004 il est incarcéré c'est
un choc violent pour ce fils de
militaire je vais découvrir un monde
dont je ne soupçonnais mais absolument
pas l'existence
d'abord je suis estomaqué de voir la
saleté la décrépitude
de la prison je suis passé avec des
criminels des gens qui ont commis des
assassinats je suis placé avec des
violeurs je suis placé avec des dealers
enfin un monde complètement étranger
pour moi une telle misère on ne peut pas
imaginer ce genre de choses sans compter
que beaucoup de Méco détenus relèvent
plus de l'hôpital psychiatrique que
réellement de la prison enfermée pierre
royale va vivre un moment d'effroi
lorsque des prisonniers mettent le feu
dans leur cellule je vais connaître une
une mutinerie dans la maison d'arrêt
donc ça se passe un soir et c'est une
cellule ou dessous de la mienne qui
casse tout qui met le feu à la cellule
donc intervention des pompiers je vois
de la fumée de partout nous sommes
enfermés je vois mes dernières heures
arrivées en 1901 c'est pas possible je
vais mourir dans un incendie dans la
prison
alors que je suis totalement innocent
pour tenir en prison pierre royale va
alors se réfugier dans l’écriture chez
lui il a tout gardé tout classé dans ses
placards des milliers de lettres reçues
pendant sa détention
et ici ce sont de nouveau les lettres
des anciens élèves que qui sont toutes
triées et que nous avons ici donc là on
est à la lettre 450 on peut monter on en
a plusieurs milliers comme ça au total
j'ai reçu un peu plus de 4 pics 4000
lettres en détention en 10 mois de
détention des marques d'affection qui
vont le toucher surtout les lettres de
son père un homme d'ordinaire très
réservé ici j'ai une date de mon papa tu
as vraiment des amis sacrés et de quelle
qualité je suis fier de toi de ce pour
cela mon fils je pense à toi chaque jour
je t'aime papa il a fallu que j'attende
40 ans et d'être en prison pour que mon
père pour la première fois puisse
m'écrire je t'aime nous prions
spécialement la Vierge Marie attendent
attention en ce 15 août je l'ai aussi
recommandé à Blandine qui part de main à
Lourdes comme bénévole nous t'aimons et
embrassons de tout notre cœur papa et
maman c'est très touchant et voyez je
suis en train de le de reprendre ses
lettres il y a quelques années que je ne
les ai pas lu et je me rends compte que
il y a des tas de de personnes etc on
n'oublie pas mais c'est toujours aussi
poignant y compris avec le nombre
d'années qui sont passés de reprendre et
de redire ça et vous pouvez regarder
vous en avez ici si on sort vous en avez
là vous en avez là vous en avez là vous
en avez là enfin c'est tout ça c'est que
des lettres
parmi les milliers de lettres celle
d'une ancienne élève avec qui il est
toujours en contact
ça c'est une ancienne élève je viens
d'avoir mon bac si j'ai réussi à faire
ce que je veux c'est grâce à vous et je
vous en remercie je me doute que ça doit
être très dur pour vous mais vous avez
mon soutien sincère qui n'a pas changé
depuis le début de cette affaire amitié
et courage Ludivine
j'en ai une autre veuillez recevoir mes
sincères amitiés je vous embrasse très
affectueusement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
visite à Ludivine
[Musique]
ça va Ludivine et toi ça va c'est d'ici
qui habite son ancien élève à 18 ans
elle a été marquée par cette affaire
elle se souvient très bien de l'énoncé
du verdict
quand vous avez appris et vous avez
entendu il est condamné à 10 ans de
prison je crois que ça a été pour tout
le monde une claque absolument
monumentale
ça peut être possible je me suis dit
c'est énorme 10 ans de foutu en l'air 10
ans de sa vie
je trouvais que un innocent condamné à
tort et ce qui a pu terrible quoi durant
toute la détention de Pierre royale ils
vont s'échanger du courrier se soutenant
mutuellement ma chère Ludivine quel
bonheur et quelle joie de recevoir votre
carte je suis touchée émue par votre
confiance et votre fidélité j'ai eu fin
juin les résultats du bac sur le journal
j'ai été bouleversée de joie par votre
belle réussite au bras au baccalauréat
et du premier coup je n'ai qu'un mot
bravo nous fêterons tous la dès ma
sortie de prison
que vous dire sur cette situation la
folie des hommes le mensonge la trahison
voilà ce que je retiens de ce procès
inique et d'un Verdi très volcan et
scandaleux
grâce à cette correspondance pierre
royale va tenir bon bien décidé à se
battre il fait appel de son premier
jugement
[Musique]
pierre royale est incarcéré depuis 10
mois cette fois-ci conscient de l'enjeu
est bien déterminé à gagner il va
préparer son procès en appel il prend de
nouveaux avocats et rassemble tous les
témoins en sa faveur
ça va être un peu procès du siècle pour
la cour d'assise du Cantal où on voit
des tas d'avocats de barreaux de
d'Aurillac qui viennent pendant les
audiences la salle d'audience est pleine
chez des anciens élèves qui viennent qui
n'ont pas les moyens de dormir à l'hôtel
qui dorment dans les voitures dans les
duvets pour pouvoir être là pendant les
audiences voilà c'est vraiment un procès
fou les auditions s'enchaînent jusqu'au
troisième jour Quentin des témoins fait
une révélation qui va changer le cours
du procès il va y avoir ensuite
l'audition d'un ancien petit ami de la
soi-disante victime qui va venir en
disant ben écoutez elle a pas pu être
violée parce que
ben moi j'ai couché avec elle deux ans
après qu'elle ait quittait
l'établissement et elle était vierge
c'est moi qui l'ai défloré
stupéfaction de la salle la présidente
tu dis enfin pourquoi vous n'avez pas
expliqué ça au procès de Rio à madame
tout le monde était tellement persuadé
qu'il serait acquitter que j'ai pas
voulu vous dire que c'était une menteuse
après 7 jours d'audience le jury se
retire et le verdict tombe
et là la présidente dit à la question
pierre royale est-il coupable avenue
d'animéité le juridique non pierre
royale est donc libre j'ordonne
immédiatement sa libération et là c'est
un silence de mort dans la salle
tout le monde pleure à la sortie de mon
comité de soutien dans la salle des pas
perdus de la cour d'assises tout le
monde se congratule je suis acquitté à
l'unanimité
Royal est innocenté mais il veut
maintenant laver son honneur il va
attaquer la France pour
dysfonctionnement du service public de
la justice et en 2007 fait exceptionnel
il va obtenir la condamnation de l'État
à lui payer 65000 euros
une belle revanche c'est voilà la
famille de de ce procès la ma
condamnation
scandaleuse est lavée
un tribunal français dit que cette
condamnation est totalement injuste et
illégale que mes droits n'ont pas été
respectés elle efface complètement c'est
en même temps pour moi un vrai
soulagement parce que finalement cette
condamnation n'existe plus
[Musique]
Florent vous avez été l'un des avocats
de Pierre royale vous êtes arrivés tard
dans son dossier est-ce que vous avez
été surpris lorsque vous avez entendu
parler de son affaire quand j'ai repris
le dossier pour m'occuper au nom de
Pierre royal de le faire condamner
l'État pour des fonctionnements de la
justice j'ai été effectivement très
surpris du parti pris donc il avait été
victime de la part d'institutions
judiciaire jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
quitté par la Cour d'Assise d'appel à
cause de son nom ses origines il a été
victime d'un préjugé de classe il
appartient à une classe supérieure
pierre royale et le cousin de Germain
notre ancien ministre Ségolène Royal
peut-être que l'institution de son n'est
pas rendu compte mais la lecture du
dossier c'était évident qu'on lui a déjà
fait payer le nom qu'il portait et la
famille qui était la sienne de manière
particulièrement injuste et là on le
voit avec Pierre royale d'un côté la
semaine chafaille de l'autre qui sont
pas du même milieu qui ne sont pas du
même milieu la faute l'erreur judiciaire
peut toucher tout le monde oui parce que
vous avez un nom célèbre parce que vous
êtes d'une famille qui appartient des
lits de la nation
contraire parce que vous êtes d'un
milieu très modeste ou parce que vous
avez une vie personnelle qui n'est pas
je dirais celle de tout le monde ou une
profession différente ou une croyance
différente ou une sexualité différente
ou des origines raciales qui ne sont pas
celles de majorité du pays et moi j'ai
toujours trouvé qu'il y avait un côté
quand même rôle étrus qui était
extrêmement et qui étant dans la chaîne
pénale vous dites quelque chose
d'intéressant vous dites qu'on est plus
sensibilité à l'injustice quand on vient
d'un milieu défavorisé d'une minorité
d'une minorité parce que je crois que
vous savez déjà au quotidien ce que
c'est que la discrimination quelle
qu'elle soit le sexuelle religieuse
ethnique raciale bon vous le savez
d'emblée donc vous êtes peut-être plus
vigilant alors vous savez vous êtes déjà
eu quelques soucis je dirais deux
discriminations vous serez déjà plus
méfiant de l'institution à partir de là
vous aurez certainement plutôt les bons
réflexes de réaction
[Musique]
accusé pour un délit qu'il n'a pas
commis sur le seul témoignage d'un
policier
emprisonné à tort pendant 5 mois
Hassan ne percevra que 15000 euros au
titre de la réparation de son préjudice
cela couvrira à peine ce qu'il a dépensé
en frais d'avocat aujourd'hui il porte
un regard amer sur la justice
moi j'en veux j'en veux et on va dire il
y a plein de personnes il y a
le premier procureur qui avait ce grand
sourire
autant en fait les personnes qui avaient
envie de voir d'être juste en fait
d'être juste en vue mon innocence et les
personnes qui avaient leurs idées
préconçues ils ont même pas essayé de
regarder voilà quoi il y a le témoignage
d'un policier et l'épreuve que tu as ça
coûte ça tes preuves matérielles
on les met même pas limite dans le
dossier ça ça reconnaissant visuelle
formelle ça les parents mise en cause
[Musique]
on partage avec qui
aujourd'hui c'est sur les montagnes
dominants Grenoble Cassan aime se
promener les week-ends
[Musique]
avec cette épreuve là et et j'ai trouvé
une autre partie de moi avec mon fils
qui m'a redonné un peu goût à la vie
même si je l'avais pas perdu totalement
il bouge
[Musique]
l'ancien directeur d'école a quitté le
monde scolaire à 52 ans il se
reconstruit lentement
[Musique]
ça m'a donné une vision de la vie d'un
optimisme incroyable je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les épreuves quotidiennes
de la vie peut apporter
vous savez la vie c'est une vallée de
larmes mais c'est d'abord et avant tout
une vallée de rose et j'ai essayé
toujours d'en garder finalement le côté
de la vallée de la rose